so I'm we're gonna talk about you like
you're not in the room right now but for
this video you know invisible screen yes
so Robert Langdon is not such a showy
character for an actor of this caliber
to play what does Tom bring I think that
no one else could uh
well Thomas this has this amazing
remember invisible screen yes yes yes
he has an amazing ability to make
everything look effortless which is what
you every single actor in the universe
that's what you're always trying to
achieve and he just he just does it
every every movie all right Tom it's
your turn so you know looking at the
poster people might go oh it's Robert
Langdon and female sidekick look the
thing about these is you know and
actually all of them is that the very
strong women characters they're
accomplished they're tough they move the
action forward
I'm always connected to these strong
strong women types who you know drag
Robert Langdon along it's rare for a a
big Hollywood blockbuster to have
something that you feel like you laugh
you learn from this movie while watching
it like good classic art and history do
you think that's what makes this film
stand out from a lot of things at the
box office
Ron Ron is able to capture all the the
fun symbols and history of Dan Brown's
novels and this one can stand on its own
though as its as its grounded in the
real facts about overpopulation and that
that's a major charging engine of this
film so yes you can be entertained yes
it's a thriller yes it has action yes it
has a love story in it
but you also leave with with with real
real deal Intel that's gonna affect all
of us it has so many international
people in it different languages a
little bit diversity did that add
another flavor to when you're shooting
of course of course sir because it's one
of the reason I'm here which is good but
at the same time I think it's a it's a
good also a good symbol there is a lot
of symbols on them dan Byrne series and
I think it's another symbol because I
think the solution has to come from
the the world himself the world has a
community and to have the international
after national and global cast it's a
symbol for the answer I hope the
solution will come from the world as one
so I think it would have why Dante why
this map of hell